Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
says he expects a vote on Kennedy's
successor in the fall but between now
and then there is a political war to be
waged that will be waged no matter who
president Trump nominates chief White
House correspondent John Roberts
continues our coverage from the North
Lawn good evening John
good evening Bret no question this is
going to be a tough one president Trump
learned if Kennedy's retirement early
this afternoon after Kennedy called and
then came down at the White House to see
him but his retirement had been expected
for some time half hour ago he came to
the White House we had a wonderful
discussion in the Oval Office with
Portugal's president this afternoon
President Trump paid tribute to outgoing
Justice Anthony Kennedy he's been a
great Justice of the Supreme Court he he
is a man who is displaying great vision
he's displayed tremendous vision and
tremendous heart and he will be missed
conservative groups aren't confident
that President Trump will pick a
replacement that they are happy with the
president has promised he will choose a
nominee from his published list of 25
conservative judges frontrunners are
said to be federal appellate court
judges Brett Kavanaugh from the DC
Circuit the Seventh Circuit's Amy Coney
Barrett Thomas Hartmann of the 3rd
circuit and Raymond kettle agenda both
apar both from the Sixth Circuit in our
country the selection of a Justice of
the United States Supreme Court is
considered I think we can all say one of
the one of the most important events one
of the most important things for our
country President Trump has the
opportunity to submit a rock-solid
conservative majority at the court for a
decade or more with the stakes so high
the president will run into a buzzsaw of
opposition in the Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer already urging Congress to
reject all of the president's choices
Americans should make it clear that they
will not tolerate a nominee chosen from
president Trump's preordained list
selected by powerful special interests
who will reverse the progress we have
made over the decades until the Kennedy
announcement the big news of
day had been a pending summit between
President Trump and Russia's Vladimir
Putin it's good for everybody so we'll
probably be meeting sometime around my
trip to Europe the foundation for a
bilateral meeting was laid today by
national security advisor John Bolton in
Moscow Bolton met with both Putin and
his Foreign Minister Sergei Lavrov at a
news conference Bolton said he expects
the topic of Russian meddling in the
2016 election to come up we did indeed
talk about Russian interference in the
elections and I expect it will be a
conversation between the two presidents
as well the leaders last met on the
sidelines of the APEC summit in Vietnam
at that time the White House said there
was no need for a bilateral meeting that
the two didn't have much to talk about
how things have changed we'll be talking
about Syria I think we'll be talking
about Ukraine I think we'll be talking
about many other subjects and we'll see
what happens so you never know you never
know about meetings what happens right
the White House in Kremlin will announce
tomorrow the wear and win of the meeting
the most likely target the week of July
9th when President Trump is in Europe
for a NATO summit and visit to the UK to
possible locations Helsinki Finland and
Vienna Austria where President Kennedy
met Soviet premier Nikita Khrushchev at
the height of the Cold War and one other
piece of news coming out of the White
House today Fox News has learned that
former Fox News co-president bill shine
will take on a senior communications
role here for President Trump while
shines official title has yet to be
decided it will likely be at the deputy
chief of staff level Rep John Roberts
table in the North Lawn John thanks